[Music]
hey everybody welcome back to City
skylines and welcome back to St Luke to
be honest sometimes I wonder what I'm
doing to myself and looking at this
timeline over here with over a half an
hour of footage and no idea how I'm
going to talk over all of it I'm
thinking this again also I got some
comments on my last video that it was a
little bit too long I've also been
getting lots of comments in the meantime
that my newest video is taking way too
long to come out so sorry about that
guys there's just something about this
game that um yeah I just love playing it
I just love building and at some point I
just have to say stop it that's enough
we're going to make a video out of this
um but usually that just takes a while
and usually I'm like H I don't want to
stop making this video I just want to
keep playing the game um so that's also
kind of how this went and now I have a
bunch of footage that I I also cut some
parts in so I'll definitely let you guys
know whenever I did something off camera
and I'll be a nice YouTuber and not do
too many things off camera but there's
only so many shots of me placing down
trees and making Farm fields that you
guys can handle probably so I'm still
going to do it a little bit this video
is still going to be a little bit long
and maybe my commentary is going to be a
little bit all over the place because of
that it is what it is sorry about it
guys um but bear with me here it it does
take a while to make these videos and
I'm only doing it in my free time which
aside from all other stuff going on in
my life uh isn't always a lot of it so
it is what it is also I've been saying
that too much in this series I know plus
there's the fact that um during the beta
or I should say the the pre-release
section of uh these videos because the
game has been released now for the past
couple of weeks but during during the
pre-release um people were allowed to
make uh videos or select group of people
were allowed to make videos at certain
deadlines so I needed to hit those
deadlines but for this video I didn't
have a deadline so it was a lot easier
to also keep going and not be forced to
release a video at a certain point but
here we are there's some stuff to talk
about so I'm going to actually talk
about the game from this point onward um
but yeah keep all of this stuff in mind
uh I know some of you guys watching
these videos might not be very frequent
viewers of my channel besides my channel
hasn't been very active for the past
couple of years so uh there's a huge
there's a pretty big chance a lot of
people aren't frequent viewers so I
figured it would make sense to at least
uh talk a little bit about uh me
personally making these videos but
you've heard enough of that anyway uh
let's go back into the game couple of
things that I didn't talk about in the
last few videos that definitely do
deserve talking about one of them is the
tree brush or at least the the tree
removal brush in the last few videos you
might have noticed me deleting some
things uh or deleting trees one by one
even when I have a whole Forest of trees
and I know that gave some people the
impression that there's no forced
removal brush in the game I certainly
thought so but when the game came out
and some friends of mine started playing
it as well and I was watching uh along
with them playing the game um I realized
a couple C things and one of them is
that there is actually a way to remove
trees uh with a brush tool also uh
somebody pointed this out to me on
Discord uh I think it was Teddy Redco
pretty sure it was so shout out to Teddy
Redco in any case if not for that then
for their discography or uh their
Discovery for how amazing the developer
tools are in the game that's something
that I'm not going to mess with anytime
soon and you can look up on their
Channel what exactly this means um but
yeah they've been doing amazing work
revealing all of the secrets in this
game anyway um back to the game there is
a forest removal brush so that's going
to make my life a lot easier especially
considering how many trees there are on
this map and how many of those I want to
be gone so that's helping a lot
something that doesn't really help is
that I had to deal with a crash at the
start of this episode I recorded for
about I think 2 hours and I for got to
save doing this whole time and then the
game crashed and then I lost all my
progress which sucks of course I was
very pissed off at that point but then
again usually when you do something
again uh you're a little bit better at
it a little bit more efficient as well
and for that reason you can see me
moving my camera very little in some of
these shots and already kind of know how
I want to lay everything out because I'm
doing a lot of stuff for the second time
at this point so while it was annoying
it did result in a slightly better time
lapse I think where I'm really a man
with a plan except for this section this
is actually all new ideas but for many
of these Farm Fields especially around
the start of this episode a lot of that
is something I already did earlier so
that's pretty nice anyway what I'm doing
in this episode in terms of you know
what am I actually building at this
point I decided it was time to build the
rural landscape around the big city and
it's not super rural because you still
have all of these Villages and hamlets
scattered all over the area it's a
little bit more dense than a real rural
area would be I guess you can still see
that you're on the outskirts of a big
city um but at least you know it's
really giving that City the context that
it needs around it to make it look like
a big city and with that I can already
answer some questions on the last video
I didn't have a lot of cinematic footage
on the last video and I certainly didn't
have any like big overview shots of the
whole area the reason for that was that
I mostly wanted to stick to cinematic
shots where you don't see any
unrealistic Landscapes there's just
something about having unfinished
Landscapes and parts of the city in the
shot that I don't really like in my
cinematics but because in the last video
I only finished the city itself and not
the area around it I didn't really dare
toh show a really zoomed out shot of the
whole city and its surroundings
and on this episode I think I'm not
going to feature too much of that either
yet I'm not going to get that far that
I'm going to be able to finish the whole
whole region so I'm just going to stick
through shots of what I've already
finished but for this episode I think
it's going to be a lot more fun to uh do
the Cinematic shots then for the last
episode because as you can see we're
really getting that rural area around
the city uh making the highway between
the city and this area and all the train
connections and stuff and we're really
getting a big realistic
region at this point so that's also a
lot better for the Cinematic shots as
well also little fun fact I don't want
to uh toot my own horn too much but I
think this town is my favorite on the
map there's just something about the way
that it's laid out that makes it just
feel really real and just right for a
village of this size we have some of the
row houses alongside the main street
that Main Street which is a little bit
curvy and bendy like it's an old mediev
street that a new town grew around and
then just outside that town we have the
new train line that cuts through the
landscape and really looks like it's
been added in the 19th century and then
the the small suburb just kind of grew
around that I don't know this is
something about the the layout of the
whole town that makes it feel a bit more
realistic than many other parts of the
map and maybe also just nice uh for
being so close to the big city it
definitely has a rural feel and that's
something which uh I think you could see
a lot in a lot of UK cities as well
small towns and Villages around big
cities that are very well connected but
when you're in that town itself you
don't really notice just how close the
big city you are and I don't know this
town just kind of felt like something
like that moving on here this is where I
decided to add my um well way of
splitting the power lines there's
something about the power lines in the
game where uh and I know I talked about
this topic a little bit in the last
episode you can just make uh
a
t-section on on your power lines which
makes no sense there's there's no way
you can do any of that you definitely
have to have some substations in order
to do that kind of move so I built a
substation here and then around the
power lines uh I really made the
landscape and paths and Roads feel like
the power lines are cutting through the
landscape here and I'm reserving some
space around them not building any
houses underneath them or anything like
that I think you can technically build
stuff underneath power Lin in this game
but it just doesn't feel like a good
idea to do that that said that is a bit
of a Dutch approach I guess because
typically in a Dutch landscape power
lines have no buildings underneath them
and if they do they're typically old
buildings and there are even subsidies
and uh all kinds of systems made by the
government to buy these houses and
buildings underneath power lines and
make sure that uh the the ground
underneath it is basically uh free not
for any health reasons um but just for I
don't know spatial planning reasons uh
whereas in the UK it's a lot Messier
usually also little tad bit here uh I
decided to add some industrial area with
buildings that look like they could
really be you know uh warehouses and
stuff like that you know really big
industrial buildings it's something that
I kind of miss with the zoned industry
and Commercial areas but thankfully
there are some special buildings in the
game which are huge huge and have a
realistically huge industrial footprint
and I think a space like this would be
perfect for some kind of distribution
center or Logistics Center for DHL or
Supermarket of sorts and stuff like that
right next to the highway uh a lot of
space a lot of very cheap land uh
perfect place to have buildings like
that so that's why I decided to develop
that over there it's also very new
Industrial Area I think which makes
sense it's the furthest away from the
city center uh it's not next to the port
or anything like that just next to the
highway and that's its sole reason for
existing it's also a good place for my
future um water treatment plant because
uh realistically I think a city of this
size should have a pretty big wastewater
treatment plant and I didn't really have
a realistic one yet I think I'm still
dumping all of my sewage somewhere in
the ocean here which is not very handy
because the water is basically not
moving and the polluted water is going
to stay around
forever um I did come up with some off
camera schemes to pump the water to a
different location but to do that you
need to build a whole separate water
system and also make sure that there are
users of water on that water system
because otherwise the water is not going
to be pumped around um long story short
it's kind of difficult to get rid of
polluted water on a map like this where
you don't have a flowing river that just
kind of takes it all away um hopefully
in a few years time uh all of that water
is gone but I have no idea uh I'm very
new to how stuff like that works in this
game of course as we all
are anyway moving on to this area I've
been building this for too long without
talking about it this right here is what
I envisioned to be a PO industrial
section of this city you know looking at
the layout of this area it's clear that
this used to be a harbor and a heavy
industrial part of the city but then a
few years ago you know with
dentrification and the land value just
becoming too high the industry moved out
to the outskirts or far further away or
to other cities or other countries even
and this area is ripe for redevelopment
into you know residential gentrified big
apartment buildings and stuff like that
a fancy new police headquarter because I
didn't have that yet I figured that
would also fit into an area like this so
you know that kind of Waterfront area
that you see in cities around the world
there probably some hamburger
restaurants in here where the hamburgers
cost 20 and there's industrial lighting
and fake brick walls stuff like that you
know the good old gentrified post
industrial area and um I also thought
this would be a good place to add my
signature skyscraper of the city I'm not
sure yet which skyscraper it's going to
be because I removed it again because I
thought the last one was a little bit
too tall so now I'm letting these guys
build a new one I'm going to go through
a few uh iterations on that that
skyscraper I think until I land at one
which I actually like but the idea is
that the signature tallest building of
the city is right here at the mouth of
the river um because this is probably
one of the most high land value spots in
the city one of the hippest coolest
yuppiest places in the city and one with
a great view over the water as well so
realistically I think uh this would be
where that typical gentrified post
industria area would be anyway moving
back to the country tree to a very very
different vibe I'm deciding to build
some more Farms here because we still
don't have enough farm land I'm doing
that weird thing with the Train by the
way just because I don't want the train
to you know um not connect anymore I
definitely still want people to use the
train and I want to be able to use my
cargo trains to get stuff to and from my
industrial areas uh but at the same time
I figured I wanted to have a different
route for this train than the game gave
me uh because having the the train and
the highway right next to each other
kind of makes it look like they're you
know the the realway is very modern or
at least developed alongside the highway
or vice versa but you usually don't see
highways develop alongside train lines
because usually highways develop
alongside old routes between cities or
other places where they can be built and
real lines are just that much older so
yeah all things considered um I figured
it wasn't the best option in this
scenario and I wanted to have a separate
reil line that would follow more you
know the uh old trajectory of towns in
the area having some towns and villages
in the valley and then having the
railway connect these while the highway
is further away from The Villages um
just seems to makes more sense I think
and with both the the railway and the
highway I'm still trying to keep in mind
you know how with this old rural fabric
have looked before the railway there are
definitely some Fields where
um you can see they are different on
both sides of the Railway but there are
also some old roads that uh connect on
both sides as well we don't just have
the railway um you know two very unique
pieces of land on both sides of the
Railway I'm trying to connect them as
much as possible and make it seem like
the realway is cutting through the
landscape here uh also here we have the
big Forest which I realized is made out
of
hickories um which is a tree that you
don't find in the European tree section
but you know it's not it's not the worst
possible scenario I think it's pretty
realistic to have them in Europe as well
so so many trees get imported to
different continents that I think you
can mix and match the different trees
from the European and American section
in the game as much as you want to
whichever extent you think looks best um
but what I wanted to do with this Forest
is make it look like the the rural
landscape has been kind of eating into
this Forest because realistically
forests used to be most of Europe
forests used to be everywhere uh
especially some of the countries in
Europe that you might know for being
typical grassy countries um used to be
much more forested that even goes for
Iceland I think Iceland used to be
almost all Forest until it became the
grassy bare land that it is nowadays uh
due to years of basically uh human
intervention um so yeah all that said
realistically when you have Forest you
can see some Farm Fields often kind of
cut into them uh up to a certain point
where people said you know we need to
start protecting this forest and making
it a national park or whatever um some
kind of hiking area so I wanted to make
it look like that was the case here too
we don't have a hard border between
where the forest stops and the Farms
begin we more have this thing where some
Farm Fields kind of eat into the forest
a little bit or maybe even even have a
field right in the middle of the forest
um it's all a little bit messy and made
throughout the years um and I think that
just ends up being the most realistic
look for things like this now I'm
expanding the rural area with some more
Village uh I would almost call this area
verban it's pretty cool word I think um
but uh yeah it's uh it's just need some
houses and stuff like that I also placed
some of those trees in the Middle where
you can see I placed a bunch of trees I
usually like to do this to make it look
like there's some kind of Creek there um
a lot of people have commented which is
very fair that this isn't the most
English looking landscape just because
it kind of likes the Rolling Hills that
you would have in the UK and I think
that's totally true I didn't dare to
terraform the map and really make custom
Hills and stuff like that that would
have been a lot of work not to mention
that it makes it very hard because you
need to keep buying uh extra tiles and
especially if you're terraforming as
well there's no way that you can develop
up until the edge of your of your map
because you're just going to end up with
really weird terraforming so yeah all
that's considered I decided to keep the
terraforming mostly As is but still put
down some areas where there are a bunch
of trees scattered in a pattern to make
it look like there's a little creek
there it's something that you see a lot
in the UK especially around small
valleys or hillsides very small forests
that kind of snake their way through the
landscape so that's something I wanted
to uh try there and over here the small
Regional highway is getting its
expansion with a new interchange and
what else can it be other than a
dumbbell interchange of course something
which I really um like doing with my
highways which I messed around with a
little bit at first in this map and then
figured out uh really works is to syn
the roads by using the terraforming tool
to just kind of make a a small Valley
build your road into that Valley and
then um smooth it all out and then if
you place a road over it you
automatically get a very small bridge
over the road but your uh exits and
entries onto the highway don't become
Bridges which I think is the most neat
look and it's also the just the way
that's that you know building is
cheapest it's pretty unrealistic to have
huge Bridges uh going with the highway
intersections because bridges are
expensive it's much cheaper to just
throw some soil on a heap or uh dig a
small uh Valley and then just run your
road through that so realistically but
also aesthetically I think it works to
uh do your interchanges like this and
the more I start building these little
interchanges with uh dumbbells and
roundabouts and stuff like that the more
it is starting to kind of look like a UK
landscape I think especially with all of
the tree lines around them you can
really see that Highway making its way
through the much older landscape but
curving just as much as all of the tree
lines and farm fields in the area
do and uh here I decided to add a new
another Farm I think realistically none
of my farms in the map so far are
actually producing anything because of
the way that Farms work in the game
which I think is a little bit
unfortunate personally I think with oil
and ore and stuff like that you know
stuff which is in the ground and only in
specific places it makes a lot of sense
to make them very local
but there's no reason to me why these
fields wouldn't be able to you know have
some Farms on them some grains and stuff
like that also this is a part where I
skipped some uh off camera sections
because there was a lot of time spent
making farms and placing down trees in a
way very similar to what you guys have
already seen so I think I'm safe
skipping that part um but yeah you can
probably imagine what it was like it was
very timec consuming but in a way also
kind of
therapeutic anyway moving on to this
part of the city this is where I wanted
to finish this neighborhood it's a
little bit more foresty it's a little
bit more on the expensive side
especially once we get closer to the
university you know we're on the hill
we're downwind from the industry so or I
mean we're not downwind from the
industry we're far away from the
industry and the industry smoke isn't
you know uh being carried here by the
wind so this is realistically where the
most expensive neighborhoods should be
so we're going to lay out some large
Road patterns and houses first I wanted
to build this small Park here with a
with a football field realistically I
don't have enough football fields in
this city this is something that
somebody pointed out rightfully in the
comment section of the last video there
should be more football fields um I just
keep forgetting that UK people are this
much into football um so there are a
couple of them in some Parks still not
nearly enough and the main island of St
Luke doesn't even have one so I have to
admit this uh was a bit of a mistake on
my part that said if I retroactively put
some football fields in some Fields here
and there I think that just ends up
looking more realistic anyway um because
you know with the growing towns and
stuff like that that's something that
had to happen over the years trying to
figure out where to put these football
fields in an already existing landscape
so we're going to do that at some point
in the future trying to figure out where
to put some more football fields but for
now uh this is the the small amount that
I have we're going to have to deal with
it and the people of my city are going
to have to deal with it so this is uh
this is really the the fancy suburb over
here they have their nice park they're
well connected to the train line uh we
have a small apartment building and some
more commercial buildings right next to
the train and maybe also some higher
density roow houses but the further away
from the train station the go you go and
the more you go up the hill the more you
start getting these residential
neighborhoods where I decided not to
fill in every single square of
residential zoning because I want to
keep as many of these trees as
possible very often I find it a nice
trick to uh just fill up the first
couple of squares or only fill up a
couple of squares alongside the road
just to make sure that all of the trees
that were already there can stay there
uh so it really looks like this
neighborhood while residential is much
more forested and is actually located in
what was already an Old Forest on the
hill here which I think makes sense now
my next adventure on this map is this
new area which is very close to the
harbor and it's between the old Harbor
Parts but it's much too large to
actually be a harbor and it's also a
little bit of a hill so realistically my
head Cannon for this part is that it's
an old Hill close to the city close to
the Sea realistically would have had
some farms and a small village on it at
some point in time so some residential
development especially at the top of the
hill um but at the same time once the
city grew and once we're going through
the Industrial Revolution this is also
the mouth of uh the river so a prime
real estate for the harbor activity so
this also heavily industrialized and
then got loads of Housing and stuff like
that and realistically I think it's not
going to be the best area of the city
it's close close and downwind from the
industry it's um yeah it's not right
next to the city center it's actually a
little bit cut off from the city center
even has that highway to cut it off from
the rest of the city as well so all
things considered not really the best
area at the same time it is you know
within view of the sea so you do have a
good view here so there's definitely
some parts here that are probably pretty
desirable so a good area I figured for
loads of uh cheap housing some Council
Flats maybe some old Victorian row
houses from the industrial era for the
workers of the city and the workers of
the harbor that's very nearby um so
maybe not the richest part of the city
but still a decently nice part of the
city I think that's worth visiting and
um yeah that's basically that I just
realized I didn't come up with names for
any of the sub neighborhoods of the city
so maybe I'll still do that um we'll see
at some point it would be uh funny to
actually come up with that but for now
this is just the uh the harbor the not
so rich area of the city with homes with
some of the best views admittedly so
there's some industry and some houses
right next to it this is kind of going
against my uh my intuition in terms of
how cities should be laid out but you
know we're making this mistake on
purpose here and there are some green
areas between between some parts of the
industry and these houses also notice
how I'm saying industry but the industry
uh is actually completely made out of uh
office and Commercial zones the reason
for this is mostly that I didn't want to
deal with all of the chimneys that the
industrial Zone creates in this game it
looks unrealistic uh you just get this
black smoke everywhere and plus I think
commercial buildings look a little bit
better as industrial zones because they
don't have all of those chimneys and
they just kind look like small Warehouse
buildings only downside is that you get
uh gas stations everywhere but I can
deal with that especially from a
distance you don't really notice how
sometimes unrealistic uh the different
commercial buildings right next to each
other are but you know that's something
that you also have to deal with also
coming on here is uh a little cut where
I decided to work on something else
momentarily but I'm just going to bring
it back to this island because I want to
keep showing you how this island looks
eventually um but you can probably see
the color of the map change a little bit
that's something about cutting back and
from different parts of a recording that
the season changes uh kind of mess up a
little bit it's it's very clear when uh
when different parts of the time lapse
have been recorded at different times so
I'm not going to try to mess with that
too much so here we just have a a
residential neighborhood uh um trying to
figure out how many row houses I can fit
in this thing and all of this time I
also realize I didn't use the trick with
the paths but I did use the trick with
different zones as you might be able to
see alongside the Waterfront here I am
mixing uh medium density residential and
mixed residential commercial zones and
making it so that every single block of
a single zone colar is only two tiles
wide and this makes sure that all of
these buildings that I get alongside
this road aren't very big and actually
connect to each other um and I think
this is the best way to get realistic
European medium density buildings if you
just let the medium density in the game
do its thing you're just going to end up
with huge flats and apartment blocks and
I think this works for Scandinavian
cities big Scandinavian cities like
Stockholm and Helsinki if we want to
consider Finland Scandinavia but um
that's a discussion for for a different
point in time I guess anyway uh but if
you make little zoned areas like this
you can Force the game to build smaller
buildings that look a bit more realistic
I think for um the type of medium
density European architecture that I'm
going for another way to do this is to
just play the game and Zone little
blocks of one well maybe for instance
mixed um residential uh at a time so you
Zone one block and then you leave two
blocks empty and then you Zone one uh
and then you leave to empty Etc and then
you fill in the empty blocks in the
middle that way you can also Force the
game to just stick to small houses but I
have no no idea how that ages over time
for instance if some houses get
demolished because they're abandoned for
some reason um you might still end up
with big uh merged apartment buildings
so personally if you have the commercial
and medium density residential demand
for it I prefer mixing the um mixed and
medium density residential um it's
pretty nice I think also I decided that
at the edge of this island would be the
best place to add some big Council Flats
um they turn out to be a bit bigger than
I thought they would be than I wished
there would be it's also kind of
difficult in this game sometimes to get
a medium-sized flat especially with
offices it's either giant skyscrapers or
nothing uh but for now I think this is
good enough and I'm pretty happy with it
I'm pretty happy with the layout of this
island overall really looks like you
have that one Old Road in the middle
which used to be like the center of an
Old Village uh but now this whole giant
industrialized area with lots of
Victorian row houses and harbor activity
has grown all around it and I think it's
a way a nice way to fill in that Island
anyway going back in time a little bit
to when I decided to do this little
intermo here this is an extra town that
I figured this map really needed and of
course we're starting off with the train
station because I think connecting the
Old Town Center to a train station is
pretty important if we want this town to
be you know growing over time and
becoming part of the bigger city that
it's connected to and that aside I'm
just going to lay out some of the main
roads for now because something that
helps a lot with trying to make
realistic um City layouts I think is
trying to just lay out the main road
roads at first you know not try to fill
in everything in between already just
stick to your main roads think of where
would an Old Village you know how would
an Old Village a couple hundred years
ago or 200 years ago how would that road
layout uh look like and then just lay
that down and nothing in between and
then start thinking about how you can
fill in some of the roads in between to
make it look like the town has grown
realistically over time so that's
something I'm doing over here as well
trying to um figure out uh how this town
would have connected to the big city in
the past so we have that one road that
at some point curves over the rail um
because realistically I think at that
point where the highway kind of touches
that road and goes over the river is
where the old bridge would have been
connecting this town to the big city uh
so the highway takes over the old road
at that point or at least you know where
the old road used to be um and then this
uh this smaller Road just continues to
the city center where a bunch of
different roads come together here we
have the highway interchange which hooks
up to realistically one of those older
roads and I thought this would be a good
place to add a big roundabout like this
it's just so much fun to do these things
it's so easy to work with this road
system in the game it's really great um
and yeah at this point I was thinking of
just placing small Office Buildings
alongside this road in the future sure
I'm going to change that a little bit
because I don't think it's quite dense
enough but for now I'm just going to
stick to that uh that town is going to
be done in the next episode and I don't
want to worry about it too much yet for
now I want to finish this episode with a
small bit of adding some more meat to
the big city itself we still didn't have
a neighborhood on the other side of the
river and I think that was a um well we
were just severely lacking that and
first of all I I'm placing this Main
Road uh kind of just based on the
terraforming it's nice to have an area
that's actually hilly because this is
where you can see how really uh natural
uh organic roads can grow over time this
road is just following the Hillside and
I was trying to uh reduce uh elevation
changes as much as possible so that's
how we ended up with this road curving
like this contour lines in the game are
extremely helpful for this kind of thing
so uh that's amazing and then I'm just
filling in the neighborhood uh between
the blanks here it's basically just
filling up the blanks really once you've
uh made your main layout
roads so um yeah we also have some big
Riverside apartment buildings and
commercial stuff over here definitely
one of the most desirable and nicest
areas of the city I think um so still
trying to put some effort into making
this also a dense but at the same time
very green and lushous area so with that
said I'm going to end this episode here
because otherwise it's just going to be
too long and I'll leave you guys with
some cinematic shots and in the next
video we're going to work on some more
of the surroundings of the city thanks
for watching and I'll see you guys
[Music]
ciao
[Applause]
[Music]